why do you want to compete with somebody
on a level playing field my main
motivation was always to be the best
sitting in a bath for hours on end
playing with your rubber duck is not
going to give you that Eureka moment
what's going to happen if your averages
something you're gonna deliver average
output confidence is not something that
you can teach people cut other have it
or they haven't did I start work just to
make money yes I did
he's a British retail magnet an
entrepreneur he's best known for his
appearance on the BBC television
programme Dragons Den in 2014 he had a
net worth of 210 million pounds he steal
poor fetus and here is my take on his
top 10 rules for success the main thing
I try and tell all my friends family
kids is do your homework why do you want
to compete with somebody on a level
playing field and be exactly the same
have the same chances of winning as the
next guy well you already know you're a
disadvantage so you need to change the
odds you need to tilt the odds in your
favor which means you need an advantage
because otherwise the next guy is going
to beat you now of course if you've got
to casino and stack the cards in your
favor what happens they throw you out
beat you up even worse even worse in
business or in life it's called doing
your homework and being prepared and
it's what you expected to do stack the
cards in your favor there's no shame in
that it's not illegal it's exactly what
you need to do in your life you do not
want to compete the same odds as
everyone else because those of you as
substitutions here these are a few
statisticians now okay no he doesn't
numbers in Oxford good that's probably
the other thing I was good at numbers
you'll find out average
is out so do your homework prepare
yourself make sure you've got the
advantage because it just doesn't come
and for me every time I'd go into a deal
or Duke I have to achieve something I
would work so hard I would stack the
cards in my favour to give me a chance
of winning and even then sometimes you
lose because that's the fact of life
you'll make wrong decisions it was said
earlier the person who says he never
made a mistake never made a wrong
decision is a person that has never made
a decision always a bloody liar so you
will get things wrong but make sure you
stack the cards in your favor
my main motivation or a star self in
business was not to make money my main
motivation was always to be the best to
be successful to have a better life than
the one I'd had up to that particular
time now money was going to be a
byproduct which I acknowledged and money
was going to be the barter tool that was
gonna give me some of those things but
actually counting the money I have never
ever ever thought you know how many
people have asked me did you have that
Eureka moment well actually it's a very
rare commodity sitting in a bath for
hours on end
playing with your rubber duck is not
going to give you that Eureka moment it
might shrink as well but it's unlikely
you're gonna have that Eureka moment for
me I've never really had an original
idea I look at other people's ideas and
I execute them if I stayed in that bath
I'd be so shriveled now so your tip is
to beg borrow and steal of other people
I think my tip is more be inspired by
other people find out what you're good
at why would you go and do something
that your average at what's gonna happen
if your average is something you're
gonna deliver average output
find the thing that you're good at
because that gives you that advantage
over the next guy and this girl you're
on this world for an incredibly short
period of time that's what I've learned
it's like it's not even a pinprick on a
rhinoceros he's asked your life span on
the world it's that short don't waste it
waiting to die find that thing you're
good at find what your passion is don't
go and do a job or do something you hate
or do not enjoy for the money that's
miserable that's not success well
wherever you reach in that in that
ladder that's not success success is
finding the things that you're
passionate about enjoying what you do
those are the things they're gonna make
you exceptional entrepreneur will take
calculated risks without the fear of
failure now that's a very special trait
I think credibly special trait to be
able to do that sounds very simple
calculated what does that mean does he
add it all up he does that it all up but
he's not worried about failing he's
confident confidence is not something
that you can teach people if they could
cut other have it or they haven't it
takes a long time for people to gather
those sort of skills of the whole
combination of skills when I was little
I used to live on a fourth floor
tenement blog and assault and TV people
jumping out of airplanes in a parable
with parachutes I'll happy great so look
what's down from the balcony I thought
I'll make a parachute and I'll jump off
the end of the balcony so it was good hi
there's my mom was at work I was very
young but I've got one of her big double
sheets attached some skipping rope to it
started making a harness
and out the balcony look down I went on
my gold oh okay I really want to do this
but it doesn't work I'm in trouble
I don't either get a five-pound bag of
potatoes so I touched a five-pound bag
of potatoes but sends it over the edge
it went down like a lead balloon
splattered on the floor and the potatoes
went everywhere they pressured didn't
open because it was a sheet
it was never I never knew the laws of
physics at that age but the point was I
didn't do it I used the potatoes first I
calculated and obviously I didn't try to
attempt it again and entrepreneur's do a
lot of that you know the do calculate
things and then they'll do things but
people like to call them risk takers
that's not the case inspiration comes
from many different ways one man can't
be everything to everybody and I think
leading from the front is important
making sure that people realize that you
care about them making sure that people
realize that actually you want them to
be a flower in your garden but it's not
always possible sometimes they gotta go
and be a flower in somebody else's
garden so you know you've got to be
realistic about it but being
approachable he's like the most
important thing for me that anyone can
approach me anyone can speak to me and
people know who I am not just as the
boss but know me as Theo another that
sounds a little bit arrogant but I knew
I was going to get that deal it's just
whether I was gonna share with Peter or
not was always going to do it I'll match
Peters offer
but mine's conditional okay and it's
conditional but the pattern stand-up
[Music]
Emraan was offered the money he needed
but the ruthless dragons were demanding
much more of his business than the
original 15% he wanted to give away a
little uncomfortable with the amount of
equity we're looking at here if we can
maybe look at seventeen and a half
percent each that's something that I
would be prepared to do so we're looking
at around thirty five percent as a as a
combination when eventually peach and
I've made the offer I could see in his
eyes was gonna negotiate actually to
really enjoy when people come back in
the NGO shape you should challenge
everything I challenge everything in my
life I changed my staff I challenge
everybody and they tell me something I
don't make sure they've got it right now
somebody offers me something I don't
make sure that's the best price we're
taking I'm taking a flier here but I
would be willing to meet you halfway
okay
I don't for 20 percent and if Theo's I'm
taking that flyer that's why so that
would mean that you'd get a hundred and
forty thousand pounds today mm-hmm you
get fear and I but for them for forty
percent as well as your finances your
expertise is something really sort of
attracts me in the individual aspects
that you can bring to it and on that
basis I would be happy to do the deal do
not be afraid to experiment or be true
to yourself and say you know what I
don't know what I want to do so I'm
gonna do it
daydreaming daydreaming is really really
good anybody tells you otherwise is a
fool daydream especially in the early
years because without those dreams they
can never ever be a reality of what it
is that you want to do you know
inspiration is a great thing and I think
about reading the newspapers watching TV
see what other people are doing some
people like to just watch and be envious
and jealous or ignore it for me I watch
people's being successful and for me it
was the inspiration the last thing I
really want to
leave you with is money is that is that
what we all think success is people
think money's about its success is that
what we all wanna do leave University
get a great job make lots of money
you're all bloody quiet on you money is
it about money did I start work just to
make money yes I did I did we were poor
we had nothing absolutely single-parent
family lived in a council flat so the
thing that drove me I needed money I
need to be success success gave me money
and then one day I woke up and realized
I had more blood in mind that I needed
and I was still very young so what was I
going to do stay in bed no do I need
more money no do I need success yes I
need the challenge I'm doing something
that I'm passionate about I want to get
out of bed so the money becomes a
by-product it's a scorecard it's
mentioned earlier it's a scorecard all
is at the end of year you're feeling
this thing called a tax return but some
people do we won't mention them but if
you're a single tax return and it shows
how good you are how successful you've
been in making money that's it it's a
scorecard it's not that's not the reason
you will get out of bed so find that
passion find the thing that makes you
jump out of bed in the morning and you
can't wait to go and do it and enjoy
your lives
thank you guys so much for watching we
made this video because Steve Medeiros
asked us to if there's someone else
you'd like us to profile we have a
message in the comments below I'd also
love to know which of the 10 rules meant
the most to you and why leave it in the
comments and we'll join the discussion
thank you again for watching continue to
believe and we'll see you soon
my fan
ever been in business before my mother
was a seamstress my father's a musician
my uncle's worked in the docks one's a
carpenter so really I suppose it's from
a necessity for me I was at school we
didn't have a lot money I got free
school meals I lived in a tenement blog
I needed to make money I needed money
and needs sometimes gives you the extra
boost so I started a school tuckshop I'm
from then onwards it seemed okay
single-mindedness is very important and
that's something that you know I think
people have to have but you've got to
link that with the ability to listen
single-mindedness without the ability to
listen is a disaster
throw in some passion garnish it with a
bit of common sense you've practically
there